Steven Spielberg and back to the future
I know him I know that movie do you yeah
every year we talk to you you become a
bigger and bigger star nope still 5'4
0 the budget is so low we have to get
away with six tours
crystal ball I live for the moment
whatever happens yeah I think they're
giving me one of those uh things on the
sidewalk I don't know it could be like
outside of like a liquor store or
something I have no idea they roll their
eyes at me a lot I tend to say things
when they go out the door for school in
the morning like choose choose to be
happy then get in the elevator you guys
are the example for all of us for so
many reasons I really like that pressure
foreign